for every review I have to pick my dog's
hair off my shirt the defenders season 1
has been added to Netflix there's 8
episodes and this is going to be a
review of all of those episodes it's
going to be mostly spoiler free if you
haven't seen it all yet I'm going to
talk about minor plot points but I'll do
my best to avoid anything major this is
the culmination of daredevil season 1
and 2 Jessica Jones season 1 Luke Cage
shoes and 1 an iron fist season 1
everyone's coming together it's like the
Netflix Avengers which is pretty awesome
something I was very excited for wasn't
a humongous fan of iron fist that was
very disappointing I didn't hate the
show like some critics did but I really
really loved Luke Cage Jessica Jones and
especially daredevil season 1 and 2 this
show wisely starts out with the four
main characters doing their own thing
iron fist is trying to track down the
hand Jessica Jones is trying to track
down a client Luke Cage is trying to
help a kid in Harlem and daredevil is
trying to not be daredevil because he
doesn't want to hurt those closest to
him anymore but you can tell there's
something underneath him that's antsy
there's something about not doing that
at night that's really getting to him it
feels almost as if he's not himself and
instead of just having them all plowed
together in one episode to fight bad
guys from the very beginning it has them
getting used to each other it has them
running into each other at different
parts and you get to see them slowly get
into the idea of working together that's
something they captured really well in
season 1 they don't just have all four
of them come together and are like hey
yay we're a team we're awesome people so
let's be a team and fight bad guys
all four of these characters are very
damaged people and most of them are used
to doing things on their own so for all
four of them we get to watch them try to
get used to the idea of accepting help
because most of them are so used to
doing things on their own because
they're all very special people and
they're not used to the idea of
accepting any assistance from anyone
else and most of them Matt Murdock in
particular are very worried about
hurting those closest to them by making
enemies which is why he wears a suit now
this brings a lot of comedy to the show
because out of the
or defenders that are in this version of
them he's the only one who wears a suit
and so whenever he puts it on you get a
lot of great lines especially from
Jessica Jones Krysten Ritter once again
is excellent as the basically full-blown
alcoholic superhero who really doesn't
want to be called a hero which is
another great theme in the first season
of the show none of them really think of
themselves that way they don't view
themselves as superheroes there's an
entire episode dedicated to the fact
that the majority of them don't even
like that word now as I said iron fist
was my least favorite show in the
Netflix MCU in my review of season 1 I
said that I hoped iron fist would be a
more lighthearted presence than the
defenders and he absolutely is out of
the for he's probably the one that
presents himself as most giddy about the
prospect of a team-up he's the easiest
to convince that it's a good idea
because his mission is against the hand
and when he finds out that three other
people are in their own ways on that
same mission he's like yeah let's do it
why is everyone so upset about this and
Luke Cage is like I don't believe any of
this which at times can be a little
distracting because this takes place in
the MCU where the Avengers happened
aliens invaded the city it should be a
little easier for him to believe these
types of things but that's something we
have to get used to because whenever New
York is in danger
you're automatically thinking why don't
they just call Thor Iron Man why they
just call Captain America that's just
not how this works and we kind of have
to accept that we have to give these
characters time to breathe it's not like
every human that exists in the MCU is
going to sit down and believe everything
they hear because the Avengers happened
so I like the fact that Luke Cage is
still this hardened guy who's very
grounded and down to earth and very
nitty gritty and he doesn't really
believe much of anything until he sees
it Finn Jones as iron fist I feel is
better in the defenders than he was in
season one of his own show and a lot of
that has to do with the material he's
given much better material here his
character is more compelling and his
mission is more compelling there's
something to do it's not just like a
bunch of business
there's minor business stuff in the
defenders and that was easily my lease
they're part of Iron Fist but they use
it wisely here he's able to use his
resources in ways that can help him
track down the hand let's talk about the
hand in this show you finally get to see
the five fingers of the hand the leaders
of this organization Sigourney Weaver
being the top head honcho and she's
excellent she's highly intimidating and
she sidetracked conventions of the type
of character she plays that was
something I heard her talk about in an
interview she didn't want to be viewed
as an ice queen or just some bitch
that's really mean who everyone's afraid
of she's extremely refined and very
complex there's something about her that
makes her vulnerable that adds a lot to
her character and I appreciated that she
wasn't just some mustache twirling
person who is really good at killing
people you can actually understand her
ideology and you can see where she comes
from in fact she even says in one
episode that for a war to happen both
sides have to believe that they're the
good guys and they did a good job of
showing why this hand organization
things that they're doing the right
thing
Elektra is back as well and they really
got her right here I mean if they
explore things that aren't necessarily
in the comics I'm not too worried about
that I like the way they took her
character I thought she was also pretty
intimidating and a complete badass and
once again Charlie Cox as Matthew
Murdock aka daredevil just knocks it out
of the park daredevil is one of my
favorite superheroes as far as comics go
its Batman spider-man and daredevil
Frank Miller's work on daredevil might
be my favorite comics of all time even
more so than Batman and I have tons of
Batman comics I am just so glad that we
have a good cinematic portrayal of
daredevil I didn't hate Ben Affleck's
work as the character but the film
needed a lot of work I'll talk about
that movie one day I'd love to mike
colter again as Luke Cage is just the
epitome of badass but there's such a
great level of humanity to him through
the writing and through his performance
where you can understand that he doesn't
want to use his strength or his
abilities for anything other than
helping people in fact there's a lot of
times when the team is forced to make
really hard decisions where he just has
to stand back and it's like look I'll do
this but no one innocent gets hurt no
one and they all have to be like yep we
agree we agree on this right there's a
lot of comedy that comes from their team
up that really works for this show
because it's not just for people coming
together to fight bad guys they really
do a fantastic job of humanizing these
characters to show that it's really just
for really damaged people who have a
tough time working together with anyone
and they have to get used to that the
action scenes for the most part are
really fantastic I would say my
favorites were episode 3 and the season
finale there's some really great fight
choreography there's a few episodes
where it's too dim though too much in
the shadows and too many cuts but for
the most part they do a really good job
of making it look badass at times the
show can be just a little uneven because
it's for storylines crashing together
and there's a lot of subplots that are
developed from the other seasons of
shows that are momentarily addressed
throughout this first season of the
defenders and whenever that happens it
can sometimes feel like the writers have
to like they're being forced to be like
yeah I feel like these characters would
talk about that one thing that happened
before but it doesn't really do much of
anything for the defenders continuity
but they feel almost like they have to
have certain storylines and characters
there one thing that definitely bothered
me was Karen and Froggy's inclusion in
this season they have to be there it's
important for them to be there now I'm
going to get into some spoilers if you
haven't seen daredevil season 2 big
warning for you since they now know who
Matt is as daredevil they don't like it
they don't want him to get hurt and
they're very much so against it and it
kind of makes their characters a little
annoying in this season because you
really want to see daredevil and you can
recognize that he really needs that part
of his life and it's a big arc for his
character in this season but whenever
they're around they're just giving him
for it I'm like guys you don't see
what he's trying to do here and it kind
of made those characters that I found
very likeable in daredevil
season 1 & 2 annoying in this season and
just like with basically every MCU show
there's at least one episode that drags
that feels like it's sort of a setup
episode that needs to shuffle characters
around to get them to a specific place
this show has one episode that's like
that where it was fine and but for the
most part that's just because I was
already so invested in seeing these
characters that when you really loved
characters from a show you can accept
one mediocre episode because you just
want to know what those characters are
up to and that happens with TV shows
it's bound to happen and there's at
least one in the defenders where I was
like okay let's let's get to the meet
here misty Knight from Luke Cage is
included here who was a great character
in that show
but again similar to foggy and Karen
she's sort of that one person who's
scrambling to figure out what's going on
and sometimes she can feel like she's
halting the plot it's needed to make our
heroes feel some pressure from the law
so that they understand that they can't
get away with everything but her
inclusion at times can feel like that we
were like alright you guys are just
getting in the way of what needs to
happen but it does make the story more
interesting and I'm willing to accept
that rosario Dawson is back again
and always really good in these shows
and I'm glad to see her continuing to
have a huge part in them and once again
Jessica Henrik is back as Colleen wing
and her character is a welcomed addition
to the show and I'm glad to see her
getting more screen time now I can't
really explain who this character is
because it's a spoiler and I told you I
wouldn't get into that but there is a
character that shows up towards the end
and I was just like why do we have this
person again I just I don't need to see
this person I can't really get into it
but I was just like just go away I
didn't like you the first time I saw you
I still don't like you in this show why
are you here it's not the actor it's the
character and they brought a specific
character and included them again in the
show and gratefully they're not around
for that long but still I was just like
really again with this like we already
did this we don't need this again also
the last 20 minutes of the final episode
messed with me so hard there's a shot of
iron fist on a rooftop
that's how I'll put it I went no you are
not going to do that don't do that to me
I was like I was gripping my fists I was
no this can't be what they're going to
do and then there was more after that
and I went off okay okay you guys got me
you got me good
they found great ways to make their team
up very funny but also compelling
reasons to delve into the past of all
four of them and show why it might be
really difficult for them to accept help
I had a great time with season one I
thought it was a lot of fun I think the
Netflix MCU is back on track with a
little bit of a rocky season of iron
fist it's great to see them doing some
good stuff again I'm going to give the
defenders of b-plus
guys thank you very much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]